let me start by saying congratulations
on the movie you were all fantastic in
it as a longtime queen fan I was very
curious how the final live 8 thing would
be done and it's so effing good um I
just want to know like if you guys could
talk a little bit about behind the
scenes of filming the live aid stuff
because it has it's amazing energy that
you want to like sing along as it's
happening you know we we started out day
one with live aid and we went through
every song in sequence till the last day
of that week when we did the entire
concert together and I think that's when
we felt at our best you need to go from
one song to the next to really have that
same adrenaline rush that they had we
had an audience of Queen fans out there
recreating that iconic concert and it is
it's an adrenaline rush like you could
never imagine yeah it was we'd studied
that footage like endlessly in the
lead-up to filming and I remember every
time watching it just being mesmerised
by by the whole thing but particularly
just Freddie's ability to engage 70,000
people in one at once and I remember the
buzz of of watching that footage on my
little computer screen studying and then
being on set that was perfectly
replicated looking around and seeing
everybody in full costume and makeup
seeing the incredible attention to
detail and just having this incredible
experience of just realizing we are part
of this it was quite a surreal moment
but just what what a way to start it was
just a real privilege to be up on that
set and doing and it set the tone for
the film then it just this celebrates
return one of the things about this film
is one of those rare films where if it'd
have been five hours long I would have
been okay there's just so much to the
story and I would have been happy with
it so I'm curious what scenes didn't
make the cut and what were you sad to
see good mm-hmm probably is a 500 there
is a five-hour film but I feel like the
assembly the initial cut was probably a
four and a half hours and I'm not
kidding
Freddie a crazy little thing called love
he wrote it and
he wrote it in a bathtub he got the
inspiration for it he asked for a guitar
and that's where he created that song
and we shot that scene I was kind of sad
to see that go we'll see it somewhere
down the line we did the whole Live Aid
sequence as well so the songs that you
see in the film I think you only see
three of the six songs that they
actually played on the day so there is a
version of that whole concert but it's
been cut it's just been cut and we're
gonna get to see it soon and though and
then you will - yeah yeah that's gonna
be an ex coming later right yeah
anything else yeah there's a John
Deakins introduced as sort of this like
really accidental rock star he's just
like working like doing like a little
like soldering and they kind of come up
to him and asked him to join the band
and that was something I really wanted I
wanted to get in because you see that
like it's such an atypical story like
hey this was just something for the
weekend it's just something in his spare
time that he was doing he never thought
that Queen would like blow up the way it
did and so before he knew it he was in
the biggest band of all time like
without even almost realizing it and so
that was sort of a funny thing that I
wish we had gotten in there and I
haven't seen the final cut you know Dok
is is 39 in there no no I would say
thought we play this on 39 in Japan and
that for me was one of my favorite days
of filming in mist that I love that song
right so which leads me to my next thing
Queen no matter what songs you put in
this movie and you partly entered it but
no matter what songs you put in this
movie there are 20 other songs you want
to see in this movie because they're so
good for each of you what's the song
that you wish had made the movie if any
I star such so tough because like you
have to cut down that list obviously
like you say I mean my favorite Queen
song is White Queen as it began of Queen
- but yeah but there's not really a
place for it in the movie so you know
which the game the game is so clever
flash flash theme good for selfish
reasons I'd have liked Brighton Rock
just to have learnt that amazing guitar
riff yeah but I gotta say there are a
lot of Queen songs in the film right I
mean the whole the entire film is school
like Queen at one point I think we had
35 Queen songs in there to start but
yeah we're obviously gonna miss a few I
would have always loved to see the
making of under pressure because that's
such a great story but under pressure
does make the movie the soundtracks I
got to go but the soundtracks amazing
Queen pans are gonna lose their minds
but that's why I was saying this is a
story I could have had a 5-hour cut for
yeah yeah yes so did all of us we didn't
get our way seriously congratulations
thank you very much thank you
you